just tell you this was a fun [ __ ]
podcast it was fun what I wanted people
see is why I like Jones like why I enjoy
hanging out with you because I have had
to defend that because of this narrative
disagree with Alex and whatever if I was
Charlie Manson I should be able to come
on your show give the devil a big blue
smoke you would interview them would you
want to stay a certain distance away
from the devil the devil is very
sexually seductive stand up will you
just please just go to an open mind
saying the devil it's yes I have hotter
now Joe
how sexy is Adele I wouldn't say sexy I
don't think I could get it up in front
of a demon no not demon this is Lucifer
oh the big one Ted the big daddy you
know you never know till he's kissing
you I guess okay you've seen like The
Hobbit remake and so Ron's not made his
body yet right he looks like Daddy like
that fire I've seen exactly that so you
want to talk about what that real
controllers of the greys are elusive
Sauron have you ever had a significant
head injury what happened I've been
polygraph you so many piledrive to you
yeah what did it do to your personality
sometimes when people have had injuries
especially it seems like yeah you know
stuff just got better that's good timing
I'll be honest with you I'm kind of
[ __ ] no no that's gonna be a
soundbite they're gonna put that to Mon
watching music
[Music]
I'm kind of [ __ ]